this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Monday the 12th of
December the joint is brought to you by
manscape listen tis the season to shave
your nutsack manscape is the One-Stop
shop all your holiday needs right now
the law the lawnmower 4.0 will help you
trim your tree and shave you all the way
down to the [__] trunk of death
manscape is here to make the holidays
shopping a blast if you got a
grandfather and Uncle a [__] dad a
brother who's half a [__] mooc
manscaped is what he needs he needs a
piece of ass and manscape so right now
get 20 off in free shipping at
manscape.com
Joey j-o-e-y that's 20 off and free
shipping at
manscape.com Joey manscape get your
jingle balls ready for the [__]
holidays the joint is also brought to
you by Blue Jew since you're cleaning
your [__] dick I'm gonna give you
some pills to fool to fuel that stick of
death the temperature is dropping but
you meet the thermometer is staying hot
thanks to Bluetooth blue chew is an
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but in chewable tablets all at a
fraction of the cost take the many time
and be ready whenever an opportunity
arises I love blue true you could take
it on the go empty stomach full stomach
you're ready a sling dick within minutes
and the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com you consult one of the
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescriptions within days the best
parties it's all done online no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting online at the
pharmacy Bluetooth tablets are made in
the US of a and shipped and a discreet
package nobody knows nothing you
understand me if you could [__]
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to sling dick blue shoe can help
try Bluetooth for free that's right it's
Monday free day
using promo code Joey just pay five
dollars for shipping that's it five
dollars for shipping I'm gonna give you
a month's supply for free that's
bluetooth.com with Coach Joey for your
first month free for December so you
could sling dick and when Santa comes in
show me a little pink helmet he'll
[__] leave you an extra cookie visit
bluetooth.com for more important safety
information I want to thank Bluetooth
for sponsoring The Joint now without
further Ado let's get this [__]
started Jack
foreign
[Music]
what up you bad [__] Monday the
12th of [__] December what do
you got 12 shop the 10 days left the
[__] Christmas you better get to it
Chop Chop there ain't a lot of [__] left
on the [__] shelves either
it's a great weekend I'm looking forward
to another [__] great week especially
here on the joint before we get started
I got to tell you about a little [__]
uh story that happened this weekend
Saturday my daughter had a game whatever
the [__] and uh I get there when the
dads are there and the moms are there
and we're all talking you know and as
I'm walking out one of the dad says to
me hey Joey I got something for you he
goes I picked this up in the city the
other day take a bite and I look at it
it's mushroom chocolate 100 milligrams
of THC with mushrooms in it right he
goes thank you for the gummies he goes
uh I want to you know pay you back
whatever okay
so he goes uh how many do you want I go
just give me like what's it say he goes
one is the same thing as the sillies
mushrooms except this is chocolates it's
like the the back the Box said like one
for clarity like three to four if you
want some movement and like eat the
whole bar if you just want to [__] so
he goes do you want a piece I go give me
half the [__] ball you know it's a
hundred bucks give me half the [__]
boss so I do that I come home and uh I
eat some other Edibles that I got from
uh not the True Dough stuff ones but the
heavy duty ones from uh
whatever the [__] Stoner club right and
it's like the Cherry ones [__]
stronger than [__] the whole bag's 500
milligrams I just ate the whole thing
it's Saturday night the UFC's on I got
[__] going on at six o'clock I forget
all about the mushrooms the whole
[__] thing I run some errands I run
over to my buddy's house we eat some
dinner
I come back home my wife my daughter
home it's got to be 9 30 you know
I'm high like I could feel the [__]
uh the THC the mushrooms haven't kicked
in yet I didn't know if that kicked in
with all the [__] I took last night I
didn't know if they were gonna kick in
so my wife and I are watching something
on TV
and also she says I'm starting to get
tired
I'm not going to finish this with you
whatever this we'll watch it again
tomorrow night whatever
like okay so I'm thinking you know it's
10 o'clock I'm gonna probably go
upstairs and I'm pretty [__] high
but also my daughter runs down
and she's like Dad can we put on The
Addams Family and I'm like sure why not
I'm not doing anything you know we
usually watch The Honeymooners on on at
midnight so I thought she was gonna I
don't know I don't know what I was
thinking but all of a sudden she's
watching the [__] Adams Family and at
this time like now my eyes are starting
to get like [__] you know like I'm
going like this I'm not seeing streaks
it's like I don't know I don't know how
to describe it maybe triple Vision
double v i don't [__] know
so I'm like I gotta like squint this
[__] to watch the TV and I feel the
mushrooms starting to hit me now like
I'm giggling at The Adams Family right
I'm giggling and my daughter's it's the
movie right with the with the the Puerto
Rican dude is uh whatever and uh
Angelica Houston as the [__] mom
whatever the [__]
so there's a scene man I'm just sitting
there I'm getting my I could see that
Mercy's kind of looking at me like that
you're giggling a little too much
tonight you know what what's going on
with you something's not right
and I [__] uh there's a scene where
Lurch gets out of the car I don't know
who's playing Lurch guys but Christina
Richie's whatever Wednesday and the
other [__] Pugsley and
the Lurch gets out of the car and the
little girl goes drink this Lurch or
some [__] a lot of mushrooms are
starting to hit me I'm getting into the
movie right
and next thing you know she gives the
drink to Lurch Lurch is like okay and he
[__] drinks it and it's like some
pepper it's got some fire in it and [__]
all sudden
alert just goes he'll just hit some this
thing just hits him and then he just
goes
and it's just pure fire it comes out of
his mouth I'm like what the [__] but
there's an Indian an Indian like an
Indian a statue of an Indian or an
Indian
standing there and when he blows the
[__] fire it just destroyed the
Indian goes on fire I mean they're gonna
have to cut that scene out of the movie
that's definitely I'm losing it because
it's politically correct and two years
ago it's an old movie I mean Raul Huli
has been dead for [__] 20 years I
think the guy who who played whatever
and uh dog I just lost it it was like
being eight in the eighth grade it was
like being a [__] kid at a goddamn
Pink Panther at the movie in Jersey City
New Jersey I [__] lost it there was
like two other scenes that they did that
I lost then the mushrooms kind of got
overpowered by the THC thank [__] God
but when Lurch blew that fire out of his
mouth
and that Indian just burnt the duck and
then they showed the ending and the fire
disappears I think the mushroom tapped
into it it's really interesting what
they're doing with these mushrooms even
the sillies
it's like a little buzz it's an
enjoyable [__] buzz you're not in
deep the whole time on those mushrooms
the whole time I've been eating these
sillies I've had one accident
one night I went over to the city and I
think I ate I lost count
I hit like three on stage two when I got
off five more on the drive and when I
walked in that door I was hiding [__]
and again it was a Saturday night and my
daughter was up
and I had to sit with her with those
[__] things just on fire and she's
asking me questions but if you got a
chance to watch The Addams Family I was
[__] dying I had you know guys what
it's not like I go to the [__] video
store and I'm like I want The Adams
Family but The Addams Family is blowing
the [__] up lately with this Wednesday
show this Wednesday show I saw something
that
they've gotten more hits on this
Wednesday show than anything like
anything strange time Strange Days
[__] stranger things I never seen
that either but it just destroyed it
it's so weird how they're doing like
these movies and doing little shows now
40 years later look at the Karate Kid 40
years [__] later and you got another
franchise Network you know sick Cobra
Kai and they're selling T-shirts I went
down to somewhere the other day and they
had a cobra kai Lego or something one of
those [__] things I'm like Jesus
Christ that a cobra cry book at Barnes
and Noble about a month ago
and now you know this is a series that's
[__] I grew up on that series when it
was in black and white with the original
Festa
and now you know you got Wednesday it's
it's just [__] amazing what they're
doing with old ideas guys I do a [__]
movie of the week and it's crazy I'm
patreon it's crazy what you know because
I have to look into the movies and read
a little bit about them and think about
them sometimes the movie's on I
forgotten about but it's like all the
movies that I [__] like I would give
up as a movie of the week but you see
how all those great I give a lot of
movies out from the 70s guys and I don't
want to sound like that [__] dude I
don't want to sound like Quentin
Tarantino or Scorsese you know for me
those were you got something on those
movies you left those movies going what
the [__] did I just watch whether it was
The Exorcist the original Longest Yard
you know now I go to a movie and I leave
and I forgot I even went to the [__]
movies I went to one movie I remember
this year wakanda forever that that's it
you know because another reason why I
remember it is the Mexican dude from
Michael's in that [__] and he's
got little boots that make him fly
around so the whole movie I kept telling
my daughter hey I told you Fairies Wear
boots no they don't dead no they don't
It's [__] amazing guys what they're
doing I gotta tell you something else
when I was watching that [__] movie
Saturday night
I was watching Raul Julia
and for you [__] that don't
know
I'm gonna tell you something
they talk about all these great actors
and people who could [__] let me tell
you something wrong here was a [__]
Savage and if you don't believe me just
the range he had to do like a kids movie
like Adam's family this [__] did
a movie called Tequila Sunrise
[__] with [__] Mel Gibson and
Kurt Russell about a drug dealer
he's tremendous in that if you've never
seen Kiss of the Spider Woman holy [__]
is raulia [__] great in that movie
Raul is a Puerto Rican [__] Savage
the funniest thing ever there was a kid
in L.A and I was running around telling
people he's Raul your son
I swear to God this guy for [__]
years and the people like really you're
Raul he's a great actor he would cry
then it came out that [__] that guy
wasn't even Raul Julia's DNA I think
Raul Julia's wife made him take a DNA
and there was no DNA and it came out and
he was like the laughing stock at
Hollywood who the [__] knows anymore
with these people Welcome to Hollywood
[__] I got this interesting
[__] email the other day
guy on patreon was talking to me about
uh
every once in a while man listen you got
a lot of stupid [__] from people you get
interesting stuff from people
a [__] Jake cattell sent me the
[__] article
of when I robbed the jewelry stores and
Snowmass he found them not the original
Snowmass time one but the Snowmass son
which got released on Sundays and it
says more burglarized on Christmas Eve I
get great [__] you know he hunted it
down this is the second time a third
time he's helped me out Jake with this
type of [__] but uh
I get some great emails I get people
just send me like questions uh what's
your favorite band what are you smoking
tomorrow you know whatever
but you get some people that really like
uh hit you home and you're like wow
that email threw me for a [__] Loop
and he said that in this email that uh
I never like to give out names because I
that's not my bag somebody said to me
why don't you you talk to people on the
phone because I don't want people to
hear other people's [__] problems I
like to bring up a problem to discuss
how I would handle it this isn't even a
problem it's just something that people
need to know especially this time of the
year
when people are thinking of changing
[__] up you know people like you know
what
I'm thinking of quitting drinking for a
while or maybe I'm gonna give pot a
break December 31st or maybe I'm gonna
stop with the pills or the coke whatever
the [__] your poison is you know
it's so weird I have a friend now who's
uh
he lives in California he's a big dude
and he got diagnosed with something and
he called me we're talking about three
weeks ago he was telling me how he's
going for the surgery he gained a lot of
weight all of a sudden but in all my
conversations with him like he has to do
a little workout against the surgeries
like in January and he's been trying to
work for I got a couple friends that are
doing the surgery next year but this guy
is a big guy that just got hurt and he
never could work out again whatever the
[__] the story is but we've been talking
he it's really weird how these two
stories connected
always talks to me about when he has the
surgery how his life is going to change
and I'm happy for him I'm his brother
I'm here for whatever the [__] he needs
but
it's like your life isn't going to
change that much unless you change it
you know when you're talking about
losing weight it's a lifestyle change
when you're talking about
not drinking no more it's a lifestyle
change when you're talking about not
doing drugs it's the lifestyle change
when talking about losing weight it's
the lifestyle change they're all
lifestyle changes you just not quitting
something you're just not walking away
from something your whole lifestyle has
to change you know when when I got on
Weight Watchers yes I thought it was a
[__] diet
but no it's not you're just going to eat
fruit today and then tomorrow you're
going to go and eat two gallons of Ben
and Jerry's even though I love [__]
Ben and Jerry's New York super fudge
chunk when you're a stoner there's
nothing better than Ben and Jerry's at
night but
you know you when I went to
uh White uh White Castle when I went to
[__] him the Weight Watchers I didn't
know what to expect you know and as I
went to more meetings and I got involved
I learned you know they tell you to go
to the meetings because
it makes things easier and I found
Honest Engine and when I was going to
meetings I was losing more weight right
I was losing more weight right so
it was a lifestyle I realized that I had
to incorporate a gym with it I realized
that I had to drink [__] water I
realized that to lose weight you gotta
sleep sleep is important so it's a
[__] lifestyle change it's not just
that you just stop eating well I'm just
gonna stop smoking pot I'm I'ma stop
drinking but what are you gonna do now
what are you gonna hang out at the bar
no you gotta change your [__]
lifestyle you can't see those people no
more that dude with the [__] that
does three martinis and an onion for
lunch you can't be hanging out with him
no more you're trying to change your
life I know you love the guy you know
you love the [__] but you have
to keep it calm for a few weeks so it
becomes a lifestyle change
the question this guy dumped on me was
which was [__] brilliant
he goes and say he stopped eating
oxycontins like he was on oxycontin for
like eight years and alcohol and blow
but his main poison was oxycons
he went to a rehab the dude's
intelligent as [__] he's an engineer
I mean I'm not dealing with like a
street level guy here
you know he's been on uh patreon for
about a year so
he said he went to a rehab
went to a sober living facility it was a
lot easier than what he anticipated
because they always scared the [__] out
of you when you try to quit anything you
know oh it's going to be so rough you're
going to puke your dick's not gonna get
hard you know he said that he adjusted
to that [__] easy a lot easier than uh
what he expected you know
but he said that he sold the six months
and he just can't get it together
like people still treat him weird and
you know he has no confidence and
the guy's got two kids I mean uh he has
a good job
but you could see he's lost and and I
tell him listen
keep hitting me up you know like we've
been talking about his sobriety for a
few months now but this question baffled
me and I you know sometimes you ever get
like somebody asks you a question and
they put you in a spot like you gotta
[__] answer them that's not fast
sometimes let me think about it give me
a [__] day to think about
what you know that's the only way I
could answer it uh I don't know the best
of my ability you know there's some
quite hey when are you gonna when are
you gonna jerk off Tuesday morning you
know that that's easy to say but what
are you gonna do this I [__] have no
idea you know
there's questions that you need time so
he goes you know it was it's just been
so weird
how quitting was so easy but adjusting
has been a [__] he goes if I
would have known I would have kept
eating the [__] bills and I'm like no
you're doing the right thing so I you
know I just I didn't even answer them I
waited for a few days I got I went for a
ride I went to the gym you know and I
thought about the [__] quiet you know
something happened to me Monday this
week it was great news I got great news
about something
I didn't even process it until like
Friday I wasn't happy about it like
Friday morning that's the type of guy I
am like it takes me a couple of days to
that's a great question you know
and I was thinking about when I got sore
but when I got sober
I got so like mid-november I got I was
in a movie so I didn't for 30 for 20
something days in a row I I was involved
in this movie there was no really going
out at night and the other time I was
down I would just stay home and hide I
was just staying home and hiding because
I didn't want to do Coke I didn't want
to see anybody who would make me think
about Coke and I really wanted to quit
and after about it was like I think that
December
and I never said nothing to nobody
when I quit cocaine I didn't say [__] to
nobody because though you know how it is
when people say hey I've been clean for
30 days you're like give this [__]
guy another week I'm still not gonna
leave my wallet and yep you know just
because you've been sober for 30 days
doesn't mean I'm gonna leave my wallet
in front of you know and guys I'm not
being judgmental but this is just the
way it is guys you know
so I didn't want to say anything I
didn't want to be that dude you ever see
that dude disappears for 60 days and
also you see him and he's drinking water
and he's got like a headband on he's
like I just left the gym I feel great I
haven't done a drug in 64 days and
you're like you [__] mutt you know
there he is trying to make everybody
feel bad like I'm working out now I
bench 400 pounds you know shut the [__]
up and then the year later you see him
and you're like what happened to the gym
oh you know whatever the [__] so I
didn't want to say anything I didn't say
anything till [__] maybe February but
I'll never forget that January working
at Cobbs Comedy Club with Rogan
Tate Brian re Duncan we're all up there
I think I told Laurie first like Gloria
I'm done blowing two [__] months
because it was two months when we went
up the cops
and he was like come on I'm like yeah I
haven't said nothing to nobody
I haven't done anything you know don't
say nothing I don't want Rogan to know I
don't want anybody know I want to be a
sober at least a year before I raise my
hand before I'm a jerk off you know
and uh
that was great all that [__] was great I
could seemingly stand up was trying
starting to get a little better but I
wasn't healed it took a while to get
[__] healed
but what happened was when I was doing
powder and all that [__]
I don't know if I tell Mike this
but I always used to tell Lee I used to
go listen man
my biggest problem when I was doing coke
wasn't the [__] Coke or the money or
sleeping or getting to the job or
whatever my toughest job wouldn't I
shouldn't say getting to the job my my
the toughest problem I had was you
counting on me
like you can never count on me for
anything if I told you eight in the
morning
you know odds were not in your [__]
favor you know and it's sad it's it's
it's very [__] sad when you can't
make plans with somebody like the last
three years of my addiction guys there's
people still waiting for me at the
airport
like you know what I'm saying like I was
going to Houston and I would call they
call you at the airport I'm at the
airport I'm about to get on the plane I
wasn't even at the [__] airport I
hadn't even showered yet that's still my
living room doing blows from the night
before and I would call a club owner and
go just pick me up in Houston I'll be
there at one o'clock and then at one
o'clock my phone would start ringing
where are you I'm circling the airport
uh my plane got delayed oh no no no guys
the the [__] I did was just horrific it
was horrific I'm surprised I [__]
salvaged my career trust me I'm telling
you this there was maybe three or four
comedy clubs I [__] over that they're
still waiting for me to show up or I had
a delay even Rogan tells the story I was
supposed to meet him at Rascals in
Jersey and he kept calling me where are
you and I'm like I'm at the airport in
Vegas I'm delayed I was nowhere even in
sight
I was nowhere I was nowhere even in
sight and it's [__] sad to look back
at it and to see where my life went but
guys I could not keep it together and I
had just come off like The Longest Yard
people knew
when I Shot the movie people knew
already I was a fiend and then I [__]
over the Ontario Improv and they told
everybody
so it was very [__] rough Uncle Joey
that first year it was brutal that there
were times when I was like [__] it I
should just go back to snorting coke
because I'm getting the same [__]
reception you know
you know you quit you have this problem
you [__]
take all these years you [__] look
back you quit and all of a sudden now
people are still a little roughed here
like they're still like
you know The Comedy Store was kind of
weird at the time I hadn't been at The
Comedy Store no more I quit Coke and I
just stayed away from The Comedy Store
because I knew that there was no way
that was my [__] to go that was you
know if I went to the store I stayed out
of the store for six years but I
purposely stayed out of the store the
first two years because I did not want
to [__] be in that you know it was
rough enough going out at night having
cash having to drive home with the cash
in your pocket at the store you know it
was right there for me the coke was
right there all I had to do was walk to
the front
so I voted to [__] Coke but it took
me guys you know if you
if you're thinking of quitting anything
don't think you're like quitting is the
easiest thing quitting is going to be
the easiest [__] thing you go and I'm
throwing these pills away or I'm
throwing this blow away I'm throwing
this weed away or I'm never drinking
that's the easiest thing you got it's
the work you do afterward that sucks
dick
it sucks dick I mean nobody's gonna lend
you money right like nobody lends you
money still
because yeah you're sober but now
they're waiting for the big [__]
blowout
so for a year people were waiting for
you to fall I mean guys and you cannot
be mad at somebody waiting for you to
fall because for [__] 10 years you've
been lying to people you've been lying
to everybody including your [__] self
so now you want people to say ah you
quit sure let's open up the [__]
house and break out the wallets and the
champagne bottle no
people going to be more cautious of you
you know it's like when somebody wins a
bunch of games in a row you start
betting against them because eventually
you're gonna they're gonna [__] lose
they're gonna lose oh my God I'm gonna
bet again and then they keep winning
they keep winning they keep and then
when you don't bet that's when they
[__] lose but
it's just crazy how much of a [__]
struggle I had so when this guy hit me
with this email I was like brother
listen man I sent them like a [__] 20
minute email like about it yeah I wrote
you know I usually try to keep it my
email short so people don't send me long
[__] emails
but this one I had to put it down
because I could see the concern I still
remember like my thinking I still
remembered how much of a [__]
struggle it was
and then people were hitting me up to
give me Coke
because the craziest thing is when
you're doing coke you can't find it but
now that you're not doing coke
it was everywhere so every Club I was
going to now people didn't know I was
sober so now they would come to the club
and go hey
we brought you an eight ball and I'm
like oh hold on hold on to it when at
the end of the show I'll [__] come
get it and I would not even come out at
the end of the show
it was a [__] nightmare how much
cocaine was around me when you don't
want it when you want it it's not around
but when you don't want it now it was
[__] everywhere and I was already
like I was done with it guys so I never
had a problem 15 years I never had a
problem I never wanted a [__] urge to
go back I knew what would happen if I
just did one line of [__] Coke
I knew what would like I couldn't cheat
with a bump every piece of work I did
the last 15 years like if I if I set the
mic like listen let me just try a
[__] line if I just try the line
today all the work I did the last 15
years would go [__] the punishment
would be unreal to [__] because the
promise I made was never to do it again
so the punishment I would get as a man
would be unreal so that was the easiest
of mine but it would make you think you
know when you're [__] a junkie when
you're a [__] Savage like I was half
of my game was people coming up to me
going hey can you get me an ounce of
coke sure you know
I would take an eight ball out put an
eight ball of cut in I made sure I got
you the best Coke in town but I threw
some cut in it that's how I made my
[__] money you know if I was having a
bad week I would throw extra cutting it
if I was having a really bad week I
would just take your money and not give
it to you you know that that's
I would disappear for a month you'd be
looking for me for a month where the
[__] is he I gave him a thousand dollars
he told me he'd be back in 10 minutes
that was 10 weeks ago
but
when I stopped doing coke guess what
happened all of a sudden everybody
wanted to buy coke for me
I still write a dog I remember one time
like I couldn't get nobody to give me
like 250. like there was a couple Comics
that gave me money for eight balls and I
would go to El Compadre buy the eight
ball
do two lines and not even give him the
eight ball back there's three big name
Comics that gave me 250 for an eight
ball at one time and I just went and did
it and never saw him like a month later
and they never even brought it up
like they never even brought up
and then there was people from time to
time that would give you like you know 2
000 bucks and go get me as much as you
can there was one comic that's a dear
friend of mine he caught me on a bad
[__] week and I just gained like half
cut and he called me back he's like I
can't give this to the people I'm like I
don't know what to tell you
do what you can we didn't talk for about
a year or two then he apologized I
apologized
I told him what I had done and you know
I gave him some pot or something we
[__] made friends but I
I I still remember being like so but two
months and somebody called me up and
like can I talked to him I'm like yeah
can we meet at like Starbucks sure
they were like dog I got like [__]
8 000 bucks or something something that
I sat there and was like
and I remember the guy going what are
you giggling but I go
I'm just thinking about if you would
have done this gave me this the last two
years I was snorting coke
you would have never saw me again he
goes what do you mean I would have never
gave you [__] eight thousand dollars I
would have gone to Vegas I would have
gone up to [__] Vegas and just did
the eight thousand dollars worth the
[__] blow I wouldn't have given you
nothing he's like thank God you're not
doing coke anymore thank God
it was it was just surreal the test that
the Universe gives you
the universe starts testing you a little
bit to see if you're really [__] and
that was the thing sober wise like
I had it covered I wasn't not gonna go
back to cocaine and that's the proof is
in the pudding I never slipped or
anything but the pressure
is what drives you
[__] want to do a line and to be
honest with you guys I never came clean
about this but I used to hit [__]
meetings once in a while
just off meetings I would hit him
especially in the valley when I first
moved to the valley
there was a couple little meetings
a couple of them were AA a couple of
them were n a it didn't [__] matter
to me with [__] junkies what
differences it make you're not going
there being I'm not I never drank before
who gives a [__]
just listen to their stories I would
just go there and listen to their
stories I never [__] I think I spoke
one time in like eight meetings
I never and I didn't go like every other
day I didn't really have a sponsor I
just had the schedule
there was one on uh there was a little
one like a Russian one by my by my house
I didn't want anybody to recognize me
and [__] this is before podcasting and
stuff so I would just hit a [__]
couple meetings no Stigma attached just
to listen
and you would go in there and go [__]
you know
wow if this guy's putting up with that
because when you go to those meetings
you hear people talking about word [__]
than what you're going through I had a
place I had a girlfriend I had a job I
was doing stand-up I had money coming in
you go to those [__] meetings you
hear stories about people that have
nothing
like they're living in a shelter and
they come back they lost everything and
that's a difference that you need that
not because you'll go [__] I'm better
than they are but because you go you
know what I thought I was having a
[__] bad day this [__]
is really having a [__] bad day now I
feel a little better so that was all
those little things help me comedy
helped me
my friends helped me
uh but like I said none of my friends
were recovering [__] addicts like I
couldn't talk to Joe Rogan about it or
Ari or or Duncan they just were like you
know okay we'll watch you we'll watch
you from time to time and
but again that was the the wanting to do
the drug was the easy thing I didn't
want to do the drug I just wanted to get
over what was going on around me I just
wanted this stigma that I don't know if
they it's like when you get out of
prison when you got out of prison you go
to shop and Shop Right all of a sudden
you're like this [__] guy knows I
just got out of prison I could tell by
the way he's looking at me you know what
I'm saying like you just feel that
everybody is looking at you like why is
everybody [__] looking at me
you know and that's what happens when
you get off the [__] drugs you're
like these people know I robbed this
these people know I did Coke these but
you know and they don't know anything
it's you that's walking in there on edge
because
one of the [__] most truest stories I
heard
when I was on The Longest Yard there was
a wardrobe woman who was [__] a
hippie and she was tremendous I really
enjoyed her company every day she would
come in every day I'd go come on dog
when are we gonna get stoned and she go
oh I'm not I haven't gotten high in 11
years I went to Woodstock she's one of
those chicks that went to Woodstock she
seen Jimi Hendrix the whole [__] deal
and she would always say to me and I was
doing blow then she I don't know she
knew it she didn't
but she would always say to me
you know what's weird
when you stop smoking pot and see the
world for
and I would look at like why would I
want to do that
you know when you stop smoking pot
and you see the world and you see the
things you miss and I would think about
like what the [__] she talking about
well guess what
that happens when you give up alcohol
that happens when you give up pills that
happens when you give up Coke when I
gave up Coke I heard sounds I never
heard before
you know like you just hears it's like
when I put my hearing aids on at night
you know and I go pee I go [__] I never
heard my pee hit the water like this it
hits it hard you know what I'm saying
like seriously when I put my [__]
Hearing Aids on at night I hear [__]
that
you know I don't put my hearing aids on
the daytime I don't need them I need
them at night because the sound of the
television bounces so I have to control
it you know when I go to a restaurant I
have a hard time at those places but
when I [__] uh you know
when I put my [__] Hearing Aids on
it's it's like a whole new [__] world
but that's the thing that sounds the
best when I take my dick out and I pee
holy [__] when the P hits the water I'm
like what the God my [__] my ears can't
take it that's a that's a that's how
[__] that's how deaf I am so it's
just really weird that's what happens
when you see like seeing the world
without those [__] things like for me
it was 29 [__] years
you know you don't see nothing you don't
see martians but I'm sure that your
[__] affects your brain thought I
know for a fact I know for a fact I
found the video a couple years ago two
years ago when I moved here some jerk
off put it up of us talking in his yard
and I was on coke then I could not even
understand me
I was having like eight conversations at
once with 10 different [__] people
and it's it's it was not good
so when you start hearing these things
again
and you start seeing things you haven't
seen in years you're like what the [__]
is that
you just haven't seen that [__] you've
had you know you've been high for
[__] 30 years what the [__] did you
see it's so funny when you read uh Henry
Hill's daughter's book she has a great
book I don't even think you could find
it anymore she wrote a book right after
Goodfellas saying that he was a liar and
she didn't say he was a liar she just
goes listen man let's be honest
when you're doing that amount of drugs
how much of a memory do you really have
for him to remember all that stuff she
goes I remember waking him up and he
didn't even know if he had to go to
[__] work the next day he didn't know
my wife's name he didn't know my
brother's name he didn't know my
sister's name so and then I even have I
I take that into consideration with me
also I was so high after [__] time I
don't remember a lot of [__] but I
remember a lot of [__] because I have a
memory of a [__] of a [__]
elephant you understand me I remember
[__] everything you know I look at my
daughter now
I asked my daughter a question about
something the other day
talk she repeated it back to me
she was there at the moment
it was so vivid and so clear
and I remember being a kid and my mother
saying to me holy [__] you got a great
[__] memory like you you just
described something to the T you know I
asked her about it I talked to a friend
of mine on the phone a village he goes
like did I tell you I met your daughter
I met her in a party and I told her you
grew up in my house and stuff I saw the
other dog you never told me you met a
villa
she goes she's like and she's like a
willow I didn't mean no [__] a
village yes you did you met him at uh
Lisa's [__] birthday party she goes
oh yeah yeah yeah little guy built no
hair she described them to the [__]
tea North Bergen shirt on the whole
[__] deal you know blonde girlfriend
I was like
you know that's the memory I [__] had
this happened a month ago but that's the
memory I [__] had as a kid my memory
is not that [__] bad but it doesn't
really matter we're not talking about
memories we're talking about the memory
got erased okay we thought about that
how the [__] the memory got erased
it's always a fun [__] Monday Morning
podcast
I love the Monday Morning podcast
because we get to [__] talk about
something that
I just love it that we could talk about
something that's gonna you're gonna
build on and I'm gonna build on and
we'll you know just me remembering what
I went through that that year that first
year of sobriety it was brutal
it was [__] brutal I remember getting
better on stage though I remember
noticing after six months and not doing
powder I remember noticing [__] like the
number one thing I stopped sweating on
stage
holy [__] when I was doing coke and I
wouldn't do coke before I went on stage
I'm talking about doing coke the night
before
getting those days the day after and
[__] puddles would be coming out of
my [__] body I don't know how that's
cocaine affected my sweat the next day
on stage but that was one thing I
noticed immediately but that's just the
vanity [__] you know it's just smelly
[__] I'm talking about my timing was
better I always one of my biggest
problems always in comedy was me and
Mike would discuss a joke all week
and we would discuss it for five [__]
minutes before I went on stage
and I come off stage and they go you
didn't do the joke
[__]
that
[__] and I would kill like I
would destroy that room but I would be
furious because I've always forgot that
one [__] joke
that was my ammo all the [__] time
when I got off stage Ari and Duncan you
didn't do the joke you didn't do the
joke you didn't do the jokes [__] that
was my thing once I stopped doing coke
though I went up there and I remember
jokes I never even wrote yet you
understand me I remember jokes that
Jesus told at the Last Supper that's how
good my [__] uh everything was
cooking on gas so if you're thinking
of getting off whatever the [__] you're
on
for 2023
just remember Rome wasn't built
overnight guys the hardest thing is not
going to be you getting off it you know
they're gonna you're gonna have your
night sweats and you're going to want to
jump out of window for [__] the first
week but after that you're like
what the [__] was all the fuss about I
didn't die and I could do this standing
on my [__] head and then it's just
you getting back into the
into the routines getting a routine to
get you away from those freaky [__]
people that you were doing drugs with
not that they're bad people
not that they're bad people just for a
little time you just need a little
breather until you can handle yourself
under them
and you know if you need it man I tell
you I don't want you to think I'm
captain AA but [__] it works guys it
works and hey that [__] works you know
if you just want to maintain you don't
want to say that's the best thing about
those things you can just go there sit
scratch your balls and listen drink the
[__] terrible coffee put a dollar in
the basket and go home you'll get
stronger and that dog I didn't do it
every week
but from time to time whenever I was
having a shitty week or a shitty day I
would pop in a meeting what the [__] who
gives a [__] and if they got a fat man
meeting go to that one whatever the [__]
uh you know if they got the one Al-Anon
where you're married to somebody who's
an algae go to that one I don't give a
[__]
I did all that [__] guys and it helped
me and yeah you're gonna have your
[__] periods when you get off the
[__] you're gonna see the real world for
the first time in a long time you know I
remember a couple weeks ago I was going
to Philly and I was getting dressed and
I went to put pants on and [__] and also
I'm like I wasn't feeling good and I'm
like wow
this is where I would take a Xanax
this is what I would think of Xanax
right now
because of how I'm feeling and it would
just [__] take away the feeling right
away now I'm not taking the Xanax and
I'm learning to live with these feelings
it was the same thing I had to do with
Coke
same same thing I have to do with Coke
it's a lifestyle change it's not a
[__] diet [__] and that's the
morning Monday Morning podcast I don't
know what else to tell you [__] I
got a lot of great uh reviews from you
guys on Stoners club they're really
helping you guys out they finally got
the laughing gas in stock I think they
got some sashimi
the new Sashimi that's stronger than
[__] debt so if you want some
laughing gas hit him up I don't know if
it's a New York Market or the New Jersey
Market remember Uncle Joey one word ten
percent off for Life [__] who's
better than you and for you
[__] that are asking about
laughing gas the sweatshirts t-shirts
the merch just go to laughing gas.com
use cocoa and get 10 off your first
[__] order it's that simple it's a
beautiful Monday morning we had a couple
[__] weeks till Christmas
this is the best [__] holiday I'm
having so far I have nothing on my mind
I don't have to do any comedy throughout
the holidays and all this is about is
just getting high having a great time
with the [__] girls my friends Mike
Lee when he comes down
on the 26th and this is what it is guys
so
it's a whole different world it's going
to change for 2023. I love you
[__] have a great day stay
black and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors Jack
all right I want to thank you guys it's
a short one today I'm with no [__] I
got things to do and people to see but
you got the message listen tis the
season for clean balls manscape is the
One-Stop shop for all your holiday needs
dad has those nasty nose heads save his
life with the weed whacker nose and ear
and head trimmer he'll [__] love it
and Grandpa's gonna love the lawnmower
4.0 the electric razor Advanced Skin
safe technology is a life changer that
reduces Nicks and cuts on the [__]
sack of love you understand me manscape
is here to make the holiday shopping a
blast everybody needs [__] manscape
your disgusting Uncle your grandpa with
the nose with the hands coming out of
his [__] nose and the three-inch
eyebrows get 20 off and free shipping
with code Joey at manscape.com again
that's 20 off and free shipping with
code Joey at manscape.com manscape to
pick the perfect gift for the holiday
season the joint is also brought to you
by Blue chew listen you ever want to
sling dick over the holidays but yet too
much [__] eggnog
blue shoes here to search change that
around what's blue true Joey Bluetooth
is an online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis only in chewable tablets at a
fraction of the cost you could take them
any time and be ready whenever the
opportunity arises or whenever you bump
into a freak the process is simple you
sign up at bluetooth.com you consult one
of their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
is to talk that online you don't need to
see nobody Bluetooth tablets are made in
the US of eight and shipping a discrete
package if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help try Bluetooth for
free when using promo code Joey just pay
five dollars for shipping that's
bluetooth.com coach Joey for the first
month free I want to thank Bluetooth for
sponsoring The Joint I want to thank
Bluetooth I want to thank manscape and I
want to thank you [__] savages for
having my back on a Monday morning I'll
see you cocksuck this Thursday morning
Tip Top Magoo stay black